[Music]
[Laughter]
you know what that intro music means
good evening
welcome to theory fight night or
whatever time that
day it is for you uh more accurately
it's this kind of political theory fight
night which is what happens when you let
victor choose the reading thanks very
much
at least there was some like edge lordy
post structuralists for you to enjoy
yeah um this is our actually of the
fight night this is our third
jacques in a row oh [ __ ] i didn't even
realize that the last two featured
jacques derrida and and while i was
taking my
my notes for this episode i just wanted
to give
a shout out to the og jacques
this is of course brian jock
who first inspired my reading of fantasy
in the broadest sense which i continue
to this day
um do you guys know who that is no idea
who that is the guy wrote red ball
yeah i never read the books i watched
the show for a
couple seasons um
never really got into it though never
never knows my childhood in the 90s with
books and tv shows yeah they're
great it's a arthurian anthropomorphic
mice but as a nine-year-old
i can remember crying twice or for two
reasons at least
one because i didn't have any friends
and two because martin the warrior who
is a mouse
uh his girlfriend mouse got killed by a
slave
owning weasel and then he had to leave
all of his friends
so yes i felt great empathy to the point
of tears
for a fictional sword-wielding
mouse and isn't it the tragic
irony that the interest by which you
cope with having no friends
also that which guarantees that you will
not have any friends in the future by
virtue
of those interests we're friends it's
okay yeah
yeah i feel that um unlike
medieval animal farm fiction
we we here do not feel that strange
women in ponds handing out swords is a
basis for a system of government
[Laughter]
that's critical best way to wrap in a
bunch of pop culture references uh into
a singular hole there
what's that are we saying they can
become a narco-syndicalist is that the
idea
we must learn from the mice chomsky i
don't know can you relate chomsky to
this
i guess uh habermaus and honeth are
probably very aware of chomsky
yeah and the universal grammar we
haven't even actually said what we're
doing today yeah who is brawling here
who is brawling it is fight night um on
one side of the screen
player one insert coin
jacques rancier so our our third jock
of the mentioned in the hour and insert
coin player two axel hohneth and you
might be asking
who the hell is that well victor is
going to tell you
again he picked this episode don't worry
uh someone else will be picking next
week
did you hate this this much pills well i
i didn't know who he was but
i really i felt like i was reading
habermas
and sure enough when i checked he was
supervised by habermas
and at least i know that he has one
thing in common with habramos and that
he was born ostensibly born into this
world
to lose debates because
habermas as you know was handily
defeated by
godhammer lumin foucault and i don't
know if rawls beat him or not of course
i wouldn't
i wouldn't have read that one but uh
i feel like he's carrying on the
tradition here i don't know anybody who
thinks that gautama won that debate i
agree that he won that daredevil seems
to have won the debate against him even
he seemed to concede that but
it's also it's also where he's kind of
gone downhill
since some of the nazi connections came
up i was just gonna say it's worth
also stressing that in this case like
the verses is a very direct verses it's
actually in a book
uh like published which is like
specifically framed as
uh like a debate between the two
thinkers which
made it uh i guess kind of easy for us
to
because there's even a section in the
book where they're going back and forth
on certain points so i thought that made
for interesting reading in my opinion at
least
and i thought there was enough
post-structuralism and stuff and rancier
was interesting enough that i was hoping
that you guys would still find it
interesting
yeah i shouldn't pick on you because
it's also all about
recognition and we've constantly
it feels like bring brought up the
dialectic of recognition so this is
the dialectic of recognition as a
foundation for
politics which is honest view honest
yeah or
is that how it's pronounced honest i
don't know i don't know hero
horn i think who knows eric you know
german would you say honest
i don't know so it's did does he have an
um lao on his own no
then it's probably horneth
yeah so i mean i so i can explain i mean
you just said he was supervised by
habermas but yeah he's a political
theorist who
is like does come from that lineage of
critical
theory via habermas so in that case
isn't really critical theory or true
critical theory because
and he tends to come down more on the
liberal side and he's he grounds
a lot of his um political thought on
this kind of dialectic of recognition he
wants to ground like justice claims
on this idea that there's these spheres
of recognition that
um he kind of aligns up with um
a hegelian dialectic of recognition of
sort of how the subject develops
through being recognized by others and
he kind of infers from that and makes
his own
version of that and tries to say that
justice claims are
grounded on like a lack of being
recognized and
or in other words um that the
subjectivity of the p
of the citizens in this political state
haven't sufficiently developed or are
just
are suffer some deficit in a sphere of
recognition
and and he said basically says like
justice claims and emancipatory
struggles
are really just struggles for
recognition um based on those dialectics
if you want to know something funny uh
pills you're not the only one who found
his work a little bit bland
um so back in 2014 axel honett wrote
actually a pretty good book called
freedom's right uh that i quite enjoy
and i'll probably
draw some arguments for when discussing
this uh but he released a book
just two years later called the idea of
socialism where he said the number one
accusation leveled at this book was it
was boring not particularly radical and
didn't say anything interesting
so i wrote this book the idea of
socialism to just say no no no i am
actually like radical enough
you know we can resuscitate this
socialist ideal and like the 20
any tens you know and that'll be kind of
hip and different right so
don't worry he seems to have some
anxiety about this uh as well as a third
generation frankfurt schooler
you gotta get back to that radical core
i love how it's like a valid critique
now that your book is boring and so that
somehow indicts your theory
i mean even kant wrote that about his
own critique when he wrote the prolega
after the first critique he said this is
like long
dense boring tract that nobody's gonna
read and he said that about himself
well like freedom's right is a good book
and i think one of the arguments that he
kind of rehearsed here
about the importance of social or civic
freedom as it's sometimes called
is actually extremely important and
legitimate as a critic critique of
right hegelians uh hegelianism and it's
worth noting that one of the things that
honeth and the others did that i think
was genuinely innovative
is in the 1980s um
hegel was kind of going through one of
his periodic tenures as kind of an enemy
on the left
and starting in the 1990s you had these
kind of center-left figures like honest
like sayla benabib uh like charles
taylor probably most prominently in his
book uh
essay the politics of recognition that
kind of resuscitated his
uh reputation and tried to use him to
advocate for multicultural
pluralistic broadly social democratic
policies right and hannah is very much
in that school but as the quantifiers
have said
a lot of people don't find his kind of
tolerant multicultural democratic social
democracy all that interesting
so he seems to be trying to move in a
bit more of a radical direction recently
allah you know this resuscitation of the
idea of socialism and workplace
democracy and his reason
i guess for our audience to help you
locate haneth he
he is the current fourth generation
leader of the institute for social
research
in frankfurt germany which is housed and
originally known as the frankfurt school
so
after um after horkheimer
somebody took over who was it was it
wasn't marcuzzo was it
some i think there was a sort of like a
a um
a period where they were all in america
after after horkheimer
kind of in the 1930s what happened is
they all had to flee nazi germany and it
was actually eric fromm
who was able to get them an appointment
at columbia it's actually kind of an
interesting story because what happened
is
fromm was originally the only person who
got an appointment at columbia
and his condition for them accepting him
uh was he had to bring they had to bring
the whole institution along and
originally colombia said no
we didn't want to bring all these german
guys but prom was so hot at that point
that eventually he got his way and so
everybody kind of transitioned over
there
wait if they were at columbia why were
they all living in cali
i i don't know i imagine that they
stayed there for a little while and then
they transitioned outwards afterwards i
also don't imagine that there was really
a big expectation that they spent a lot
of time teaching
you know it seemed like adorno and
horkheimer wanted to spend as little
time there as possible
from judging by their writing and then
and then after this sort of uh
period of of uh exile they came back and
and the third wave was headed by jurgen
habermas
who is who became extremely old as
people do over time and then
um next guy took over
hohneth yeah and i mean honeth is no
spring chicken himself
but uh hoeneth is the fourth sort of the
leader of the fourth wave
of the frankfurt school becoming ever
more liberal each wave
yeah yeah and to the other side of the
debate i
was also surprised to learn that rancier
is still alive giving that he has i mean
i don't know this at all but i assume
that he has the uh
vices of most french academics and i was
surprised
but he's i don't know must be in his mid
80s because he was
kicking it with altuzar and
derrida in the 60s already so um
i'm a bit of a rancier head out of
practice i should say out of practice
roncierhead
but as some of our listeners
actually most probably do not know i
have a degree in art
and when artists want to read a
philosopher they've
they've picked something that says
aesthetics on it and that's short
so because it's short and because it
says aesthetics on it
uh rancier's politics of aesthetics
is commonly read by artists also
commonly misread by artists because they
have a
little bit of a difficult time reading
typically
so i learned this book a few times that
during art theory
course which book the politics of
aesthetics
oh yeah so do you want to give a rundown
then of what so i already said that
honest
tries to ground his political theory on
recognition a dialectic of recognition
kind of like
i think he i think what honest is also
doing is which he gets criticized
relentlessly by rancier for
of like trying to develop a thick
account of subjectivity
because like he appeals to categories
like suffering he appeals to categories
like recognition and
and there's some another category like
um the opposition between the individual
and the community kind of thing well
that too the opposition between the
individual and the community but also
like these spheres of recognition all
have also to do with like the health of
subjectivity and how well it
functions so he has kind of like a
psychoanalytic a psychological
account of like subjectivity and how um
you know their ability to participate in
these various spheres of society
ultimately are like the ways that you
can make justice and normative claims
and i think ron seer comes at it from a
very
different perspective obviously so i
don't know if uh i i'm also i will admit
that
um i'm actually a fan of both of these
thinkers i think uh i
probably come down a little bit more on
the side of rants here at least in this
specific text but i think that they both
make mistakes and they both make good
points in this but
i don't know pills if you want as the
self-described roncier head
what's what does he ground his politics
on
well he i mean the easiest way to
describe him is
as a deconstructionist um but he makes a
politics of aesthetics
in the sense that you need or that in
politics
at least in capitalism uh you don't
really have a choice
to you don't have a chance to reorganize
sense
and he means sense in like the kantian
sense of sense
sense perception where uh if you're
if you're some sort of artist and not
specifically artists right where you
have a broader sense of aesthetics here
but a formal rearrangement of the
material world
either through poetry or art or some
kind of
some kind of reorganization of material
organization
allows you to reorganize
the world sensually in some way yeah
aesthetics isn't like a theory of beauty
anymore in
a lot of these modern texts it has that
broader meaning of sense experience
like aesthetic meaning the opposite of
anesthetic when you don't feel anything
right right and the idea is that like in
capitalism
if you don't have capital you don't have
political power but everybody has
aesthetic
power like anyone has the capacity to
uh you know write write poetry for
example so
a radical politics in that sense and
then for him
politics is always deconstructive i
think he says all politics is
is insurrectionary for me um and this is
one of the things that hannah
just kind of denies it he just goes
later in this text i don't get it i
think he says something like
i'm sure there's an argument here but i
couldn't find it so here's three
possible options for what
rancier means but yeah if you if you
know derrida
well as uh as we we kind of do
then uh that's that's the approach that
rancier takes to politics is that if you
operate from the center
out or we might say is from the top
down then it isn't politics because of
politics
of maintaining the center is the
opposite of
doing politics so if you're maintaining
something as it stands
then you're doing nothing thus you have
no power thus
you are not a political actor at that
point
right and i think like the well go ahead
eric i was just gonna say he has some
very interesting
ways he defines these terms things he
says about politics like um
for him for him um what what politics
actually implies
is a kind of equality right because he
says things like um
like a king who has a divine mandate
to rule that's not politics or
a bureaucracy or a
bureaucracy of experts let's say who who
have this mandate to rule based on their
greater knowledge of things
that's not politics either because a
political system
implies that the government is
at least ruling on behalf of those who
have no power to make decisions
rather than the claim that this group of
people
has the authorization to make decisions
so they are the ones in charge
so he kind of the reason he defines
politics as
as kind of insurrectionary or political
action
as insurrectionary insurrectionaries
because he has this sort of definition
of politics
that immediately excludes anything
that's an anti-democratic
from being called politics at all yeah
politics can only occur
where the rulers do not have the right
to rule
which means that their rulership
is always in question i mean i found it
interesting but i mean
the politics is originally i mean he
does quote aristotle but aristotle also
talks about politics as centered on the
paulus the city
i don't know how that ties in but it
seems like he's got a very
kind of idiosyncratic way of defining
politics
yeah well my it was my understanding
that he defines politics
uh like so there's he makes this
distinction
between the police and politics right so
the
politics are any moments that that that
interrupt or create a rupture in the
police and what he means by the police
is
all the like businesses usual norms that
exist in society
um are just like maintaining their own
inner logic
and like nothing changes hegemony and so
for him that's why like even
elections in a liberal democracy aren't
politics they're actually the police
because
all of those elections are just like the
same thing happening there's nothing new
going on here it's just like
another permutation of like the existing
sensible world
understanding of it and it and
everything all the forces
that maintain that businesses usual
sense of the world is what he calls the
police
and not politics can't have politics in
that politics is the only one that
actually gets ruptured somehow
um by like that we start to change
um how we perceive or think about
uh these kinds of values they're
reconfiguring they're reconfigured in
some new way
and then uh so that's in that sense
that's another sense in which
his definition of politics is
insurrectionary because
it can only actually occur when the sort
of business as usual that's my
kind of understanding term that i'm
using is interrupted and disrupted
somehow to make space for something else
to emerge
which well then subsequently i don't
think he says it in this text but
he does in other texts it's gonna
uh it's only gonna be momentary um this
i think
rancier is in this tradition uh there's
a couple others in his
uh field of thought who also think about
politics as the moment of politics right
it's like this momentary rupture
and then there's a reconfiguration
that's very much of the police
yeah there's a reconfiguration of the
police and then there's a new police
order that that's different maybe it's
better but we're not going to make a
valley judgment about it
but it's not political politics as soon
as things are back to a norm it's not
politics anymore
that's mine i wanted to say that i
personally found
this debate broadly to be very very
tedious uh not because they didn't say
interesting things but because there was
a lot of talking past one another
and i think both of them didn't really
say anything that really amounted to
anything
of great gravitas right ron sierra took
a fairly
common post-structuralist position which
is that this fixation that normal
political theorists take on
locating centers of power and
criticizing them and then trying to talk
about countervailing centers of power
has a kind of intellectualist prejudice
to it because it allows the intellectual
to speak about where power comes from
and where it should be situated i think
that that's absolutely an accusation you
could make
against helmuth right 100 and i do like
this idea
as any hippie does of kind of
narrativizing politics by not
privileging
one source of discourse over another but
allowing people to speak
of their aesthetic experiences in the
kind of broad sense that eric was
talking about
and leaving things open to continuous
interrogation right
but you know in terms of what that would
mean concretely i think find that
the answer very very thin uh not only
that he claims i think rightly that this
doesn't lead to relativism as it doesn't
uh but i do think that we need to assume
the burdens of moral judgment at some
point
and point out that not all narratives
are equal right i could sit here
listening to
an alt-right personality all day long he
can articulate why it is that he
suffered a great deal at the hands of
this minority and this woman and
she broke up with him and what a [ __ ]
is she but i have very
little interest in granting that any
kind of political legitimacy right
yeah well you're shifting the terms of
the debate by saying that
because he doesn't give institutional
examples or doesn't want institutional
examples
that means that it's a thin account of
democracy
because that's not what his purpose is
and we should say
i should say go back to rancier's um
coming up in the french academy where he
fits there he was uh
uh studied under altuzer i believe and
then split with al tsuzer
quite famously because i'll tues
altazer's revolutionary idea was that
first we're gonna have an intellectual
vanguard
that's gonna come up with all the ideas
for the revolution and
the point is i mean underlying that is
the proletariat
the working class they're too stupid to
be able to
you know lead an uprising themselves and
rancier took great offense to this idea
and said like all the
the effective revolutions that we can
ever point to are always spontaneous
the intellectuals theorize it after it's
done
which again back to what we talked about
at the very beginning why he writes on
the uh
politics of aesthetics is that in
aesthetics
everybody is equal politically
if we want to talk about political
politics in the sense that you're
making it right here then not
everybody's equal
then if you more or less if you have
money or can get
access to money and backers then you can
have a political life
but in the aesthetic life everybody
potentially has
a life and that's where we see
mass uprisings what do you mean by what
do you mean by the aesthetics is
inherently equal i'm not sure i follow
uh because for him that's has to do
with the sense common common sense
everyone has a contribution
to common sense and particular
particular to him
is through art
nobody is qualified nobody is qualified
to rule
as as another way i think he puts
everyone's equally not qualified to rule
is that kind of the idea
yeah more or less that's why he says the
one principle
of politics is always equality so if
equality is not on the table then
politics is also
not on the table right because that's
when you normalize something like a
meritocracy right wherein the best
people
are supposed to rule right then you're
getting away from that idea or
again with like a monarchy with a divine
mandate right you get then you're
getting away from that because they're
the only ones qualified to rule
yeah every single every single police
order is premised on an exclusion it's
like an important point that i think
rancier makes so like any any sort of
like
sensible business as usual structure of
the world where we're like these are our
values it's always going to be
excluding some group or someone and the
police or the being
a political moment is when those
excluded will come and interrupt that
police order
but sorry yeah we should say also just
because we're going to keep using the
term throughout the episode police
doesn't mean like what we think of as
crops police is like
the state well it's not just the state
though isn't it like also the dominant
values
of society too yeah i guess you could
say the
the whole not just the radiological
apparatuses but the ideological state
apparatuses as well
it's kind of a discursive and uh
practical consensus that goes on
and the idea is to sort of form a break
with that consensus
with political action it's a good way of
putting it introduce
previously excluded voices into the
conversation
and then there's this sort of circle of
then then it kind of becomes normalized
again and you fall back into the police
state that's
that's what kind of what i got out of it
but it's important to note that ron
sierra
is also an archivist so he did
loads and loads of work in the in the
1970s in the archives looking at the uh
history of the french working class
movements
and reading the works of french
working-class people who participated in
various kinds of political action and
discourse as well
so he draws quite a bit it's not like
his
it's all kind of groundless theory as as
we might think of it it's it's
it's grounded in some careful analysis
of some actual historical
stuff as well so he's not less
historical
in his orientation than the frankfurt
scholars would be
well this is what i wanted to say though
i think again the reason for this kind
of dispute that
pills is highlighting is again a kind of
methodological one
right and that they're coming out things
from two very different perspectives and
the tradition of french aesthetics um
kind of colored by french marxism and
the revolutionary tradition uh and the
tradition of a kind of
political science-y appropriation of
frankfurt school themes that you see
circa
like and others right so one of the
things that you find with french
aesthetic theory and i think actually
baju does a lot better
at expressing these kinds of points than
rossiere does in this essay
is this fixation on the idea of a real
politics of the event
as he calls it right that's
revolutionary
where everything genuinely comes under
contestation and where
previously excluded groups that weren't
able to participate in the routine
pulleys of their country are actually
incorporated because the legitimation of
the system breaks down
and everything comes under question
right and this is very much something
that i think
derives from their revolutionary history
right and the kind of aestheticization
of the french revolution 1789 the almost
every french thinker tends to engage in
right uh for everyone else in the world
who's not french right
uh like someone like axel honeth the
question almost immediately becomes okay
there's this moment of radical inclusion
delegitimation that occurs that's
actually extremely productive because
now you can
ask political questions that you weren't
able to before but how are you going to
cash that out practically and this is a
very serious problem right because
after the revolution is gone and you
tear things down year one is established
you need to build something in its place
and the problem with that is every kind
of political system that we've devised
thus far
inherently as ron sierra points it
incorporates exclusions into its very
makeup right
even the kind of radical social
democracy or socialist democracy that
someone like chronic would want to put
forward right now
is predicated on a kind of exclusion the
exclusion of citizen and non-citizen
which is why i think roncier's right to
bring up um how difficult it
has been for france to incorporate
people like the algerians into the
polity
right but it's not clear how it is that
you can overcome that and i think it's
right to actually raise that question
the way that he does
haneth right which is to say look you
know if you want a more
participatory political system uh you
can't just aestheticize that it's going
to take really difficult technical
questions involve very difficult
questions questions about who gets to
participate in what way through what
institutions in what time
through what kind of mechanisms most of
which are really not all that
aesthetically interesting
because frankly they're fairly practical
questions that most theorists find
pretty boring
well aesthetics and practice would be
kind of tightly linked in this case
wouldn't it
be yeah you have sort of sense as
meaning which
links to knowledge and epistemology and
then you have sense
as perception which links to everyday
existence which is kind of
rancier's the reason ron sierra has this
play on
disagreement which you have a
disagreement between
like what you know and what the world
how the world actually
like appears to you in a practical kind
of everyday sense
yeah i mean the one criticism that i'd
really raise of hanuth sorry victor i'll
let you know that
is that he's really he he remains like a
lot of these lefty aliens are
the kind of center left against people
like taylor benabib uh and hornet
he's attracted to this idea of organic
metaphors for society and politics
right that you see hegel espoused uh in
the philosophy of right that society is
best conceived as an organism
it functions well when it incorporates
uh everybody
under certain egalitarian terms yes but
qualified egalitarian terms
and if these break down what you're
going to see is disruption
uh chaos and the misfunctioning or the
malfunctioning of the social organism
and the usual left again argument rather
like he's saying is that
the way to solve this is more democracy
more recognition for groups that have
previously been excluded
and more participatory forms of politics
all of which i like right
but i do think that you could raise a
legitimate raw syrian objection which is
that
by normalizing social conflict by
incorporating it
into a kind of social organism uh
like the nation-state structure that han
remains attracted to uh you also kind of
blunt the edge
of some of these radical disparities
that we see in society
uh by neutering them and this is a
criticism so you just perpetuate them
because every creating a center and just
what you're doing now
asking give me give me the practical
solutions
which eric is right to point out they
are aesthetic give me the practical
solutions is necessarily
going to be part of that hegemony
though the the point that rancier is
making is that it's never done so when
your goal
is equality your talos of your society
is equality
then that's never done because that's a
a goal that's irreconcilable with
reality but you can always do something
sure but what i'm saying is that
ultimately there are practical questions
you can ask even about something like
equality right there's a very good book
by tm scanlon where you ask
quality of what right uh equality can be
measured along a huge number of
different metrics right yeah and i think
that's what rancier is saying you can
have
resources resources abilities
opportunities equality of outcomes
equality of cities equality of
punishment like we talked about in our
last episode
so the whole thing is to keep that thing
at the center of politics and that is
for runs here the center of politics
so you you're kind of blunting the
actual critique by saying
well it's thin because he doesn't give
me a practical outlook
or a practical model for what society
should look like because that's not the
point
okay but but it is then though in my
opinion right because i know i know you
think that
yeah but i'm right so give me a second
and the reason is that these kind of
practical political questions
are actually what most everyday politics
are about right like when we're talking
about something let's go to eric's
example
should we have a formally equal
meritocracy or should we have a more
substantively equal
social democracy right these are very
technical questions that will involve a
great deal of highly specified
considerations about how to organize the
economy how to redistribute goods
what kind of institutions we should
create both at the macro and the micro
level
most of which are frankly pretty boring
right the things that policy makers are
more concerned with rather than
political theorists
but they are absolutely essential uh to
actually answering this question
in a meaningful way right and to just to
synthesize them by saying well
we're going to end this postponed this
by saying that this is continuous
negotiation
i agree that that's true right but at
some point we also have to assume the
burdens of moral judgment
and say that this is what equality is
going to look like
as instantiated in our political
community right now and to try to make
it as inclusive and as egalitarian as
possible
and to specify what that would actually
entail at any given place in any given
time
i'll give a very good example right
before you give an example now you're
just glossing this and not addressing
why he's bringing this idea up in the
first place which is to counter the idea
of recognition as the foundation of
politics
yeah but i've already said i don't agree
with that okay well
then you're making an extraneous
argument to the text sorry not to cut
you off but
we have to stay on point here if the
issue is that you cannot demand of
someone that you assemble a model
politic for you when
politics is something that accounts for
juridical judgments in order to displace
them because those judgments are always
going to displace
particular action sure i mean isn't the
idea
that like you lay out those blueprints
for the best kind of society right and
you've already in that sense divorced
them from practice because you've said
what we should be doing and these are
the steps we need to follow and you've
already excluded so many people from
this discourse because you're
having this sort of expert argument
about
what is the best sort of society and
there's all these technical questions
which implies that normal people can't
answer these technical questions
and what you're really doing is getting
at the disagreement between how are we
supposed to be
normative how do we make normative
claims what are their proper place do
they come before
the sensible every day or do they sort
of follow from it as roncier would say
i mean the normative is one of the
central
points of disagreement here like any
question
how should society be what should
we do like give me the next step the
practical
solution to this problem all of these
are normative questions and if you just
say well that's what we need that's what
we need then you're just exactly
glossing over rancier's entire
like a huge pillar of his critique of
all of this
well i wanted to i've been i've been
wanting to say something okay
for a little while and i think what you
just said eric touches on exactly what i
wanted to say which is
to me it seemed like it was hard to tell
with roncier
whether he was really offering uh
anything normative or if it was really
just descriptive right because in a way
it seems like he's just describing and
redefining what politics
what the everyday what the like
institutional ideological structures are
what those moments are but he's not
saying anything about like how things
should be and i mean so but then he like
and i think that
my issue with him is that it seems like
he's trying to smuggle in normativity
with but like avoiding saying it and and
you know i think that it can be located
they always do that yeah of course they
always do that
but and like so hold on let me finish
here so it's located
i think in i mean we talk about
exclusion right so like
i think that from a ron sierian
perspective they get to
you know and i i mean i like rounds here
but i think that it does kind of enable
a certain kind of
broad and like kind of um um
affectively satisfying stance where you
get to be like well we're just worried
about exclusion
and it's like but without actually
saying that exclusion matters
and it seems to me that like there's
certain kind like so when he makes the
claim that like every single police
order in that case the ideological
institutional structure
is premised on some kind of an exclusion
but again he remains
apparently neutral on whether or not
that's a good or bad thing and it seems
to me that like we want some exclusions
right like we want an exclusion of i
don't know white nationalists we want an
exclusion of certain things so like yeah
like exclusion of course it's premised
but that's what i mean by there's like
an ambiguity i mean maybe it's not
amicus maybe he's just offering a
descriptive account and like that's what
matters and in which case if it's
descriptive
then it's then it's not then maybe it's
not even a criticism to say he's not
offering a normative account because
ultimately that he's just trying to give
a description of politics but at the
same time when he talks about like
it's an it's an eruption and an
exemplification of like equality of
excluded people
rearing their head disrupting it sounds
very like heroic and normative
um yeah so anyway that was just like the
the sort of like
oscillating back and forth between as i
was reading it between being like
this is normative it's not normative and
you know he even says somewhere
like i think it's like when he's
responding to well of course he's always
responding to honest about normativity i
think it's on
page 119 120 right and he's like you
know it's not that we
uh base things on or we're trying to
have a political eruption that's based
on trying to generate
um new recognition or address certain
kinds of pathologies
of in people's lack of recognition but
he says
but people do it in order to construct
another world right
uh to create a new space and he uses the
example of rosa parks right like
she didn't sit on a on on a particular
place on the bus because um
she was suffering this is about
suffering uh but
because she just was wanted to um
create a different kind of world and i
felt that this was a very strange and
ambiguous claim to just be like well
it's not premised on some kind of
suffering it's really just
imagining a new world and that to me
seems
like either smuggling in normativity or
just being uh
shifty and not admitting what your
actual commitments are so i don't know
that was
yeah i mean i see why you say that but
it's his account of
politics and his idiosyncratic version
of it that makes him push back on that
because politics is spontaneous
that is it can't be determined so if
rosa parks
sat at the front of the bus because she
was
i don't know you know suffering from a
lack of respect or a lack of recognition
then the story is just that she got fed
up and
so did politics as a result but that's
not spontaneous then that's like
dialectical but spontaneous politics or
insurrectionary politics
performs the political act for the world
they want to create
not because of what's happening in this
one and that's the important
distinction there i want to follow this
up i just give an example of actually
something that
many of the frankfurt schoolers have
started to talk about third fourth
generation character schoolers talked
about
that's actually uh indicatory of how it
is that this can be carried out
at the kind of micropolitical lens so
just you know an answer to kind of
eric's question i don't think hearing
like honest is saying that experts
should kind of resolve these questions
what he's saying is that they're
technical questions that are best
answered democratically
right in fact he's very critical of
hegel precisely for actually assuming
that
we should have a bureaucratic universal
class that assumes it has the kind of
answers to these questions
and is going to manage them on behalf of
society i mean he thinks that's wrong
and he insists on that
party yeah and i think he's very
critical of leninism for exactly that
reason right
but what i mean by the fact that you
know you can't avoid the burdens of
moral judgment
and determining the kind of forms that
inclusion and exclusion will take
uh is that oftentimes the kind of
practicality of these questions
has to be answered in some way shape or
form and it's not always clear what the
answer is going to be
and approaching them purely from an
aesthetic level loses some of the grain
that appears when we try to tackle these
things in their concreteness and one
example i'll give
that a lot of attention to was given uh
it was in canada in 2015
uh loyola versus quebec has anyone here
heard of this case at the supreme court
nay okay so it's a big case uh that
concerns how to actually recognize
religious majority minorities in canada
in the education system uh and one of
the things that the court had to ask was
what would it mean to have the most
inclusive kind of education system at
the primary level
does it mean that you teach that
religion is all false
right and teach a purely secular kind of
religious education
while some people would say that that's
extremely discriminatory towards people
who have religious beliefs right
do you teach that all religions are
equal right people
say well that could also be
discriminatory because if i teach that
all religions are equal but i hold to a
concrete religious viewpoint like i'm a
roman catholic in this case
then teaching of me that my religion is
just the same as someone else
kind of discriminates me and gets me in
a certain sense right and then other
people
have said well we should just have
private schools for
all different religious denominations
and everyone should be taught that their
religion is right
within that silo right this is a very
difficult question to answer and it's
not clear
what the most inclusive form of
education would be and then it is to
learn on the streets
yeah exactly and it's not worth noting
this is something that raw sierra also
pays attention to since it's a big issue
in quebec
sorry france as well uh where the kind
of secularist lesite that discriminate
against
islam by teaching that really there is
no god or at least he has no place in
the classrooms
is extremely controversial right but
there's no getting away around the
question of trying to devise an
education system that's more
inclusive by purely aestheticizing it
you have to a certain point ask yourself
what's the kind of education or
pedagogical model that would be most
inclusive
and i think the way to settle that circa
both ron sierra and hornet
would be democratically right you keep
using
aestheticizing diminutively which makes
me think that you don't understand it
no i'm i'm not saying that there's
anything wrong with aestheticizing
something i'm saying that aestheticizing
something in the way that roncier does
has its place when it comes to talking
about how it is that we should
include different voices that have been
excluded for a very long period of time
and not presume certain kind of
intellectual authority to speak on
behalf of others right i mean but i do
think that once we
move beyond aestheticization into the
realm of political theory which is what
honda does
that's a realm where we have to start
making practical judgments about
for instance what are going back to our
talk before what kind of pedagogical
model is the most inclusive one yeah but
you
you want to answer that and rancier
doesn't want to answer that
because rancier wants the people to
answer that when they come into conflict
with the state but you want to answer
that for
the state for roncierre now no no i
don't and i
i've said that i want this to be
answered democratically right but i'm
saying that there has to be an answer
right maybe i'm wrong here but my
general take from what ron sierra was
trying to do is almost reverse
the direction like not start with the
normative claims but rather have the
normative claims follow from the
aesthetic
because when you you think about
aesthetics right there's not it's not
that there isn't
normative claims in aesthetic
aestheticizing something doesn't imply
that you are getting rid of all of the
normative claims
in your discourse right because when you
think aesthetics
even if we're not talking about a theory
of beauty as
what most people think of as aesthetics
you're thinking of aesthetics as a
theory of perception
about how perception works about what
sorts of objects we should regard as
admirable and what sorts of objects we
should regard as
not so admirable right and these are the
sorts of things that are imagined in
say literary worlds which is why he
refers to
literature like in search of lost time
and is in
as a part of a political argument which
seems very strange right
but that's how he's doing he's grounding
normative claims in
an aesthetic understanding as opposed to
in a social sciences and social
philosophical understanding which
generally starts with ethics
which has its own kind of normative
claims and then if you go into the
logic and the sciences they have their
own sorts of normative claims as well
like we're not talking about what
benjamin called the aestheticization of
politics
which is exemplified by films like the
triumph of the will
which just completely knocks morality
straight out of politics
we're talking we're still kind of
talking here about the politicization
of aesthetics as benjamin would call it
which is to
make sorts of normative claims about
aesthetics but obviously we have to be
careful
and ron sear brings this up right like
when the working class people
wanted to get into art and writing
poetry and things like that right the
normative
assumption in that case was that they
should be writing about things they know
like you know i don't know living in the
slums or doing their jobs
yeah painting their workbook they wanted
to appropriate bourgeois themes
noble themes romantic themes that seem
proper to a different section of society
and that in itself has an implicit
normative claim but we're just not
starting
with the normative you know you forget
normative norma
is a carpenter's square and a
carpenter's square
implies a kind of ratio so what we're
dealing with whenever we're talking
about normativity
is rationality what is the legitimacy
of claims to one rationality or multiple
rationalities in
our political discussions so all that
stuff
can't just be ignored when we're saying
we're aestheticizing something because
it's not that simple
when i assume i mean this is my just my
take it could be wrong when we're
dealing with someone like
rancier who's probably not the class
clown i think he's a pretty smart guy
he's probably thought of these things
right
yeah so wait wait wait we're way too
heavy right now i just need to
at least get a crux that we can all talk
about
and that's a good one to start on is
what are we talking about when we're
talking about aesthetics for rancier
when we say we're dealing with the
sensible it's not really in a
phenomenological sense but it's also not
separate from that but
i think the closest thing would be
common sense
so rancier's big idea is that we can
change common sense
and that it's not only the powerful to
change common sense
you can be a cobbler and
be able to access reform shape
common sense and not just yours but like
communally so we're trying to get to
a politics of the common sense which
means how do these things get
generalized or normalized and then how
do you make them democratic and equal so
that's like
square one anyway someone else want to
take it away i feel like i
i feel like we may have lost a lot of
people so if we can
try to build up i mean so i mean i
really wanted to push
on this idea of grounding
like because to me the most in or at
least i thought
one at least one of the more interesting
disagreements and maybe the central one
is like
what we've been talking about in terms
of normativity and like i take eric's
point about like the
locating it in that aesthetization
doesn't
mean um you know like some sort of like
like radically divorced from normative
uh
like ideal but i think you know to for
me
the difficulty i have with rancier
even though i agree with his analysis
like i actually think he's right about
his just what i take to be his
descriptive project
which is exactly what pills described
that like there's a that he's describing
the process by which
common sense which includes the sensible
and it includes what earlier we
described as
you know the ideological and
institutional structures of of the of of
the everydayness the way that those
things get ruptured and changed and
reconfigured
reconfigured in these like moments of
rupture i think that that's compelling
and accurate and i feel like that
seems intuitive to me but i think that
you know there's a part where
roncier is disagreeing with honest claim
that
for him it's about recognition he says
on page 119
you know for me it's quite dangerous to
propound this idea of a kind of
normativity defined in terms of
the good relation to yourself it
generates an idea of a struggle for
recognition as a kind of reaction
against a state of frustration
and i thought that so this is basically
honest claim i guess is that like
these political struggles are grounded
in some kind of
feeling like we're we're not fitting
into some broader structure and there's
some sort of state of frustration this
is at least ron sierra giving
honest but then later as i was saying
earlier right he says
it's people don't struggle because
they're trying to address some state of
frustration in themselves
they struggle and he says on page 120 to
construct another world
or and that's when he uses the rosa
parks example
and i guess like that's the part where i
feel like
it feels thin to me reconfiguration of
the sensible like whatever
it feels thin and it also feels like
well is why would we care about constru
like
constructing another world it's like is
that good but he refuses to say why we
would want to construct
another world he's like no no there's no
he's like there's no uh state of
frustration
with ourselves that's dangerous to say
that but we just want to construct
another world
because that's what we do when we
rupture the political
so like but surely he wants to surely
rosa parks wants a different world
because it's frustrating to live in a
world where black people have to sit at
the back
of the bus like it does it seems wrong
to me to be like that has nothing to do
with
uh like like any state of frustration
jonathan did have a very strong critique
there
i think of ron sierra because rancier
didn't want to like start with
the idea of suffering and for honest it
acts as like a bridge
right between like political discourse
and what you were saying about you know
this idea of having an incomplete and a
complete self
i guess or sort of things matching up
with the self
and he said yeah honest accused if
francier wants to eject this idea of
starting with
struggle or at least use or with
suffering or at least using it as a
bridge
between the sort of what does he call it
like the individual
and pathologies versus the political
he says you you owe you owe us then an
explanation about what is the driving
force behind your ideas right
it's not desire for equality because
ronci already said no that's just the
definition of politics that's not a
desire
and that so and then it but it doesn't
start with suffering because suffering
is a negative
reactionary thing so then like what the
hell is it ronci
and then he just says it says it's you
want to create a better world but why
or a different world not even better
that's too normative it's just
trying to create and it's like what do
you mean and that's where i think that
it's good in itself right that's where
he's sneaking in that's where they sneak
in the normativity right yeah that's
where they're they're there
i i know you love this sneaking in thing
sounds very nefarious
conspiratorial but normativity does not
need to be
universalizable they're not trying to
avoid it for that reason like equality
is not universalizable because
it's always going to become a new status
quo a new police
but oh okay look look the reason that it
can't be
normative as a first step is just like
all
our other favorite french pimps they
don't want hegel
so if you ever start by going
rosa parks sat at the front of the bus
in order to move history forward
well now [ __ ] politics is history again
so ron syrian politics
is not historical it's spontaneous
so certain people i guess you're one of
them are gonna want the why
in advance why are we doing this so if
your personal answer is
yeah uh uh we should do this because
it's right
then you're probably a dialectician but
if your personal answer is something
more along the lines of
i want to seize upon a moment where i
can bear out my will and creativity in
the world
then you may be a ron syrian whose
critique of the police in this sense
is similar to the the nietzschean
critique of hegel here
i can give you an account if you want of
how it is that a lot of these people
bridge the gap between aesthetics and
politics
uh it's not particularly sophisticated
and the best iteration of it is given in
habermas late book
um truth and justification i think is
the name of it um but one of the things
that they point out did you say albert
is late book late book yeah it's from
2001 truth and justifications collection
of essays
oh i'm sorry i thought you meant the
late habermas book or like
the book died yeah that was like i
didn't know i'm expecting
it any day now it's gonna happen he's
releasing
he's actually just releasing a 400-page
book that apparently is actually much
more
marxist in its orientation than he's
been since the 1970s so just like hannah
seems to have felt the sting of not
being radical enough
habermas has seemed to decided that he's
not radical enough at this point they're
done getting kicked around by podcasts
yeah exactly he's too much of a square
so he's kind of responding to that
uh actually igor chocobroad uh pointed
south he apparently wrote an
email to igor saying that my new book is
going to be more radical than my last
but anyway the kind of argument that we
got people make it
the kind of argument that these people
make very simply is that aesthetics
constitutes a kind of cultural life
world and it's a very hegelian idea
from people which people draw grammars
symbols and images
that they reconfigure and re-articulate
in order to demand recognition
uh both from other people from state
institutions
and from various other kinds of cultural
forces in society right
and there's an indefinite quality to
this because of course just like the
cultural world of aesthetics is
endlessly rich soju will people
reconfigure
these symbols grammars and so on in
endlessly various different ways
and there's a democratic dimension to
this because the argument that most of
them will put forward is that
rather like what roncier is doing we
should
consider the different ways that people
reassemble their grammars and aesthetic
images
uh from an egalitarian perspective and
not try to privilege one over the other
right except that becomes really
difficult because of course at some
point you need to start to ask yourself
well
how do is it that we take these kind of
demands from recognition and translate
them into political practice
right so one of the examples given by
shayla benebe for example
um at length is she'll point out that a
lot of marxists have criticized the
notion of human rights
right by saying human rights is just a
bourgeois notion anytime you codify
rights in the law inevitably the state's
going to be the one that decides what
those rights are
so we should just abandon talk of rights
wholesale right
uh but many people say actually people
have been able to use the grammar of
rights
in a lot of very interesting ways
sometimes for extremely revolutionary
causes
right if you think about the french
revolution and the demand for the
universal
rights of man per se right and this
shows you that you can take the grammar
of an aestheticized concept like right
and employ it for democratic and even
radical purposes without interpolating
it in a system of control and power
and the problem is how to actually
create a kind of social order that
allows people to do that on an
indefinite basis
while still providing them with the
minimal series of concrete institutions
that's necessary to do that and also
a high level of material equality since
if they're not actually materially
capable
of engaging in these kinds of projects
then
they're not going to be able to do so
since most of them are going to be
sitting there
toiling away for capitalist day in and
day out rather than engaging in these
kinds of acts of civic participation
and rearticulation right yeah so there
is a kind of link between aesthetics and
between politics that they draw that's
relatively sophisticated again
however master's account is better than
hollis a lot better than honest frankly
i think it's really problematic in a lot
of ways right but
i think that the reason why it is that
maybe pills and i were having an
argument is that
i'm not trying to dismiss polit
aesthetics and neither is honeth right
the disagreement seems to lie and how it
is that you take for hana from hana's
perspective i think would be
how do you take the resources in an
aestheticized life world and translate
that into some kind of practice
right democratic practices so
one connection that i can bring up based
on what matt just said this
uh aesthetics to politics bridge
um is the individual and how the
individual gets rights and how the
individual gets
recognized so so for honeth he's very
concerned with
being recognized or the subject being
recognized
and rancier kind of goes oh yeah well
the state recognizes you
it's just going to call you it
recognizes you as a colonial subject if
you're in algeria and a citizen if
you're born in france
so for us here it's not that the state
doesn't recognize you
it's that the state turns you in the
kind of individual
that gets recognized and then you're
unequal
so i wondered what you guys thought
about this debate about the
individual because this is one thing
we've talked a lot about on this podcast
in terms of identity whereas ron's here
is like
we don't want identity to be the
normative
bearer of rights we want something else
something discursive
whereas honest it almost seems like he
wants to deny it yeah so you want to
talk about that a little bit
well yeah i mean so i think that um i
think that
bronzer's interpretation of what hana up
to and actually
i wrote my like major paper for my
masters in philosophy about haneth and
rawls so so i know hanneth pretty well
and i know that he is
not only concerned with how the
individual is recognized by the state
but also this broader sense of the norms
that i think
i think there's actually overlap in what
what roncier means by the police meaning
like all the ways in which
the everydayness is you know maintained
ideologically but also institutionally
and that's why honest has these three
spheres of recognition which we can take
issue with but like you know he is very
much concerned with
also just like how your your identity
gets formed not
in terms of i mean of course the state's
always going to have some sort of effect
but also like you're the everyday way in
which you
sort of interact with people at the
level of what you might call cultural
value patterns
and i think that honeth is concerned
with
changing those and he wants to ground
them in a kind of normativity of like
subjective development right and and
what he calls um
or what uh you know this kind of good
relation to yourself
he wants to locate that um in like this
hegelian dialectical account of subject
of subject development
yeah we call that the dialectic of
recognition on here right
right right yeah the dialectic of
recognition
so and i think that um the problem
that i think ron sear has is he doesn't
really
like care about any of that it seems or
doesn't want to talk about it
specifically he just wants to like issue
the whole conversation of the individual
and just wants to talk about you know
vague things like i was cr i was
criticizing him earlier for just saying
well people do these things they rupture
the existing orders
to create a new world construct
something new and it's like but doesn't
want to say whether or not that's good
and then the other thing that i would
say what is it the liz says you know
bring something new into the world
it seemed like yeah it's just just just
because i guess that's intrinsically
good or something but i don't know i
mean but of course they would never want
to say that or i i don't want to speak
of de luz but at least here for ron
sierra
um but i think there was a really
interesting debate where haneth responds
to something rancier says
with saying well why can't we change
society
like why does it have to be any maybe he
was misreading around sierra here a
little bit
but he was basically asking like why do
these changes to the existing po
what ron sear calls the police order
have to only take place
in the context of this rupture right
like why can't you work within the
system
um to like slowly erode on some
understanding of identity and i don't
know we could think of the example of
like something like transgender identity
or something it's like
there's an i think there's i think at
least there's an interesting question
about like
you know what happens that now there's
like more
recognition for transgender in the
everyday culture today than there's ever
been was that the result of a rupture
or is that just a continuation of the
already existing logic
of our neoliberal uh context right but
but the results from the perspective of
being a transgender person is likely
positive
um but like was that it was that a
change i'd be curious what you guys
think
was that a change in the configuration
of the police or was that some sort of
an already existing logic being being
the logic of it being extended to its
natural
uh conclusion it doesn't seem like that
can happen for ron sierra this is one of
those um
those points that might put the radicals
off of hohneth though because i think
what you're getting at is
his idea that instead of the whole like
political intervention
and the suspension of the political
order he was talking about well why
can't we have like an internal
internal struggle where we reappropriate
and reinterpret certain normative values
like i don't know
what you think of like he talks he gives
us one example of the housewife
and that's that's his example of
somebody trying to
like shirk off an identity that's being
imposed on them and sort of reinterpret
their
possible role in politics or in society
and then he talks about this idea of um
yeah re
like reinterpreting normative values
like
i don't know we live in a profit driven
society can we
reinterpret that and he says you know
this is this is what we might have
traditionally called reform
and then all the revolutionaries go oh
[ __ ]
yeah exactly exactly right but i think
but i think to be charitable to to
honest i think that his point is
exactly what you said but i don't i
don't think at least i don't think in
that response he was denying that it's
possible to also have these changes
occur exactly as ron siere says
yeah exactly but his point was just like
but it seems strange to be like that's
the only time
it can change no not to say that those
things don't change
not to say that but to say that that is
not political action
like if you're already at the point
where women can vote and where
transgender people are recognized by the
state
that's because a lot of people have
already done the aesthetic work of
changing
common sense and those people did the
politics well
here though i think it's really
important to know okay i want to talk
more about that in a second but came out
i'll be quick okay i promise
i think it's really important to note
the different traditions in which uh
althuzhair uh sorry which
which wrath round sierra and hoth are
operating right uh in the kind of
context of the german frankfurt school
particularly third generation frankfurt
school theory
hannah rent becomes an extremely major
figure and she still lives with people
like uh
jonathan bennett beep right and one of
the things that hannah read foregrounds
in all of her work that they all pick up
on is that the only
thing worse uh than having a state
oppress you
is not having a state that's willing to
oppress you right being completely
excluded
from the political community and having
no rights uh that anybody is willing to
guarantee
right so i think honest would argue that
demands for recognition on behalf of
legal institutions and demands for
rights for your cultural group
are a necessary but not sufficient
condition for the point of more radical
forms of political agitation that you're
arguing
uh and the example you could point to
would be something like uh algerians in
france right which reinstates should be
aware of
right in any of them would probably
much prefer uh to be recognized in
official religion by the french state
with all the
compromises that are entailed with that
uh rather than being treated essentially
as
though they don't belong in france uh
and they're just going to eternally be
othered
in that kind of civic context and at its
apex this is going to lead to demands
that
they go home like marine le pen is
saying right even though that was
that was that being short
[Laughter]
okay so version of that will be out next
week
so yeah you were saying like the
systemic logic i really i'm still
i'm still want to pick up on this point
that pills made earlier
um is the thing that ron sierra is
interested in so i guess like you know
because originally i framed it as sort
of like a question so the example of
like transgender or like
changes in the recognitional economy of
society
that happened from within the logic i
was
i posed the question right so would that
just not qualify as an actual change
an interruption in the police or or
would it be
or would you conceptualize it that way
so i guess based on what you said pills
the answer would be like no because it's
actually just a continuation of the
systemic logic right because like the
expansion
of like transgender rights or other
things that's just fitting into the
logic
the systemic logic of the society we
live in it's not an authentic
rupture yeah it's not the same thing
like the
the declaration for the rights of women
is based
formally on the declaration of the
rights of man therefore
it is just based on the sort of formal
the formal logic of something that's
already
a kind of normative principle he talks
about love in the same way kind of a
little bit of
mary wilson craft she was actually
pretty original but look when
when you're at the point especially of
legal
recognition that is of police state
interpolation then at that point
yes that is just a continuation of the
police state
but the question is how did we get there
and what political acts did it take to
get there
how did it get to be common sense that
women should have the right to vote the
suffragettes
did that they were the political actors
there
police state is still good at police so
when it comes to
transgender recognition now in the same
way if the laws
change to recognize them
then that means that politics is over
and that politics has been
you know 50 years in the making of work
by
activists by artists by people who broke
the stonewall riots
in the 60s yeah by transgender people
who came out
in spite of the risk of ostracism and
probably violence in a lot of cases so
they risk their safety
and well-being because that is the
better world
and that act of coming out to society
in the face of a lot of a bad [ __ ]
that's gonna get thrown your way and
happen to you that is the political act
so when you're at the point where
[ __ ] justin trudeau
is wearing a transgender pin on tv then
you know politics has long been over at
that point right
i think that i don't think that's i
think that fits no hold on i think that
fits with uh
with what with you know i think honest
would just say well
yeah of course i mean those acts so the
acts themselves are political moments
right when it's dangerous because it's
and that is leading to like a
reconfiguration
of the of the common sense that with
which people perceive
uh transgender people which then makes
it possible for the stage to change is
what you're saying because of those
actual
concrete acts that were dangerous uh in
that moment
um okay i yeah i think that i think that
makes sense and i think that honest
would still make
room for that but i think what he would
say would he be like the reason that
those acts matter is because
of like a recognitional uh demand that
is motivating
and because they got rights in the end
so hannah's like okay it's good they got
rights in the end now they're recognized
well it's not just about rights it's
about everything
but i'm sorry you keep saying that no
but you see no but it's not just
respected but i think that it's the
exact same thing like
implicit in horneth is a concern with
a change in the common sense values
that were required that those acts
required and the reason why it matters
to have like
regular people uh see transgender people
as different because before obviously
when they had to do those political acts
and come out and be
you know at risk that was because people
the common sense was such that it looked
down
or or marginalized transgender people
much more than it still does now
um but the reason that honest would
would support that
it's not because of rights but he's
actually concerned with those common
senses the common sense
is the thing that makes better
recognitional economy possible
well i didn't get that from this reading
though i think the problem is that these
these examples is they can both
appropriate them with their conceptual
apparatuses right honest can say
no that's an example of someone
completing
and becoming recognized and moving
towards the
this concept of freedom that he has ron
sierra can say no that's actually
someone
subjectivizing outside of like the
identity circuit
and moving towards the concept of
equality they can both take the examples
and run them through their system and
account for them
in different ways that both sound pretty
cogent to me
but then the problem and then becomes
something on a theoretical conceptual
level if they can both
just do this very easily whenever an
example
real quick though pills real quick so
you're right that it's not specifically
in this text the way that i stated it
but it is implied because it's concerned
is about the self-relationship and all
the
all the conditions that lead to a
healthy self-relationship
which would include the common sense of
society he he
he uh fleshes that out more in like his
other works
um but you're right that it wasn't
stated the way that i did in this text
but that's all
implied by his his dialectic of
recognition um
for hannah all right well it sounds good
i'd be a little less hostile if you
stated it that way
instead of being like hey you guys did
it
good job rosa parks you did what i
now say you should have done but then
what's with roncier just
saying that like not wanting to admit
that like a
constructing another world is good for a
reason like that's just weird well
can you point me to the reference maybe
so it's page 120 119 120 when he's when
ron's here is responding
to the idea where he's it's actually
like kind of like bottom
quarter he says it's quite dangerous to
propound the idea of
of a kind of normativity defined in
terms of a good relationship to yourself
and then he goes on to talk about a
female candidate
running for office because she did it
not because she was frustrated and had a
bad relationship with her
relation to herself but because she
wanted to construct another world
and then he says rosa parks also right
she sat there
not because uh she was tired um after a
day of work it was because of her right
i haven't uh inkling that this on the
right of ours
is about something we have not explained
yet which is ron series concept of the
partition of the sensible
i think yeah that's important linked to
that like
totally and we we haven't gone over it
yet and i don't think i can explain it i
i also wanted to point out that i think
there's an important sense in which we
also have to acknowledge that
the granting of rights uh by a state or
another institution can sometimes
perceive changes in the census
communists and this is something we talk
a lot about in the social legal
literature right
do changes in the law reflect changes in
culture argue changes the culture
reflect changes in law
and actually there's been a lot of
empirical research done on the subject
and it turns out it's a lot more
complicated than just assuming
cultural changes precede legal changes
so for instance in a lot of countries
attitudes towards homosexuality were
uniformly pretty negative on behalf of
the majority of people
until there was a legal change of
permitting it after which people's
minds just changed right they said well
if the law says it's okay
then it must be okay uh there are
similar empirical examples that come
referred trading to drug use
similar laws that pertain to abortion
use and probably the most prominent
example aside from the
lgbtq one is the death penalty most
people supported the death penalty until
their states prohibited it
right so i do think it's actually
possible to grant people a group's
rights and a lot of activists demand
this even in the face of public
pressures
and the sense of communists and then
hope that there are going to be
transitions in the broader culture
afterwards right and i'm using that word
and the aristotelian
and the uh isn't thomas sense of like um
of like being able to make like
cognitive judgments about objects that
share similar qualities
that's what senses communist means i
don't think it doesn't mean common sense
like we say today
no yeah i'm using it in the kind of
colloquial sense that we were talking
about it earlier on right but
you know the basic idea is that dropping
platinum for fun
well it's a fun i knew what you meant
and i like i thought it was cool and
then eric came and was like yeah
he doesn't mean that excuse me say
i'm i'm using common sense in the sort
of pseudo-pragmatist
sense of american philosophy i enjoyed i
enjoyed the reason i think it's
important though is to victor's point
right
take somebody like take the civil rights
movement right in the american south
the civil rights movement was extremely
unpopular in the american south
and it was only tepidly popular in the
american north
right uh nowadays it's granted this kind
of almost hagiography
geographic status in american culture
right but that's not the way it was at
the time
right and one of the things that's
important to remember is that it took
a lot of activists putting pressures on
political leads to grant rights to
people of color
uh before society was willing to change
right so
sometimes i get a little bit wary of
this kind of argument that we need to
wait for
cultural changes uh to lead to
the granting of rights um i don't think
that's i don't think that's what ritzy
are saying
right i'm just kind of cautioning that
so what you're saying
i think what you're saying could be
possible but would be
definitely the exception not the rule
which is that a politician could
actually do a political act
it could in theory be possible according
to ron sierra of course
well some great politicians do i mean
look at martin luther king right like
martin luther king was
such a morally upstanding figure that
even in the face of tremendous public
opposition
he was able to enact meaningful change
in the united states right he's not a
politician though
well political figure sorry not a
politician civil rights activist right
it's the same thing for activists
against the death penalty right the
death penalty was hugely popular
in most countries still is in some
senses but they really put a huge amount
of moral pressure
on state institutions uh to say that
this is a violation of human rights and
they were successful right now i don't
think anybody here would be complaining
about that
right so i think it's sometimes more
complicated than just saying we need
changes in the kind of cultural
attitudes
sometimes there's things that activists
can do that well all
those things interlink right and i think
that's actually on its point in his
other work that all these things the
legal level
the cultural value patterns level and
then also like the private
like like our own intersubjective
relationships with our loved ones
like all these spheres of recognition
interlink and interact with each
other to create like the conditions of
of like of our of a healthy
self-relationship
just give an example that we all know we
should all be familiar with 2004 gay
marriage gets decriminalized here in
canada
most people i knew were pretty
homophobic uh back in the early 2000s
which
is not that long ago right and there's a
lot of data to say that most society
almost the canadian society was pretty
homophobic at the time uh
nowadays flash forward 15 years later
there was a change of the law and it
proceeded to change in cultural
attitudes
because homophobia is now considered
just as
akin to racism uh in terms of something
that's culturally taboo
and thank god for that right uh so you
know
they're in those examples lgbtq movement
goes back to in the states the stonewall
riots
and there's a similar event in toronto
actually in canada
that launched the movement here as well
so
they've they raided all the turkish
baths and they did the same sort of
police oppressive [ __ ] they did in the
states and it
it kind of uh congealed a movement so i
mean well i think wherever you start
that you have your distribution of the
sensible
and then you have a dissenses which is
created outside of that
and that's why i think we can all agree
[ __ ] the police
that's the outcome of this entire
discussion because ultimately
i like how he chooses the word the
police too it's funny how he chooses
that word
police it's like men it's like design
it's like tailor-made for like for like
edge edge lord seduction has an
aesthetic appeal for uh
activism right but that's why for the i
think that's why
hanneth has such a hard time dealing
with ron sierra because he's like
this guy just redefined politics he
can't do that he says that's something
to that effect that's my summary
yeah i mean i agree with you i actually
thought that hannah's reactions were
pretty bad like i thought i i
felt like i had thought i thought of
better critiques of rancier than honest
himself did myself yeah but that's yeah
that's like kind of lazy roncier
obviously wants politics to have nothing
to do with
the polis uh or or to be
undermining of the polis and it makes
sense why that would be a good
in general not a historical good i think
that needs to be qualified not a
historical good
but to see your
to see the world reflect you i think you
have to claim that that's a good
because otherwise what would be the
point of doing aesthetics right i mean i
don't think that's smuggled in though i
think that
why maybe it doesn't state it i don't
know i mean there's a couple places like
so even on so on 126 there's another
moment when they're talking about
suffering right and like ron sears
really
insistent on being like we don't have
this point about suffering in common at
all and
and he says on uh you know he says the
logic
of the poli of police to define the
wrong
on a pathological basis um it's not
necessarily
because people are suffering that they
act politically acting politically very
often comes because
some forms of ruptures appear possible
yeah like an opportunity i just think
that that's
that's just something like weird to me
that it's just like it's all it's almost
yeah it sounds a bit um deterministic
it's just like
just because there's an opportunity
people are going to take it i don't know
and it's just like
he doesn't want to admit that that like
it
it i mean i guess it depends on how you
define suffering i suppose but i was
being like charitable to honest and
thinking that suffering
has to do with a deficiency in all of
these spheres of recognition that
include culture and
and common sense and all these things
and it just seems to me that
mostly i mean i i don't understand how
you could say that people just blindly
are like well there's an opportunity to
change things i'm going to take it but
like not have any
there's no cops on this like there's
nothing behind it
like like some demand like that just
seems like very strange to me but you
can see why
right you know why it's like if
something's determined
then it's not political anymore
if you're just doing something because
you're an instinctless
uh flesh creature bumping into things
then it
doesn't matter the only thing the only
way that that can matter is if it can be
spontaneous
for you yeah i think for roncier what
moves equality along as well
in his sense of everyone having equal
capacity to participate in politics what
moves that along is disagreement
whereas with honeth what leads towards
freedom and recognition
is agreement and consensus right so they
have
diametrically opposed views on that
right
and this reproduces a lot of what was
different between
uh habermas and lumen a generation
before them right
like lumen thought that when consensus
emerged this is when
society just dies because nobody there's
no more tension
right whereas what the point of
communicative action
which is habermas's theory that honest
is now
taking over is forming rational
consensus
which must be based on agreement on
normative
principles so if you have that sort of
radical challenge to this okay yeah
seeming sensible position
which produ which forces ron sierra into
some pretty saying some like strange
things like we've been
pointing out but it makes sense you know
if if vigilance
and not losing the gains that we've
already made is
is something that requires constant
disagreement with what's going on
then it makes sense to me i don't know
and if you want to hear a slaughter
of a debate a slaughter of a fight night
it's lumen versus
habermas who didn't even know that his
pants were being pulled out from
underneath him
i want to say i think an opportunity i
think we should take this an opportunity
to propose another
uh podcast on alain bajer actually
because
i think victor if you're interested in
this kind of idea of an eventful
politics
or politics of russia as it's sometimes
called raw sierras is like reasonably
interesting but
jew is really the one who theorizes on
this and systematizes it
in their most robust possible way
because he really does describe
these kind of revolutionary moments an
ontological significance and like the
capital o
sense of the word right which is that
the state always
operates to kind of establish an order
of being that it wants
and what constitutes a genuine politics
is the event where the order of being
breaks down and you realize that you can
recreate the world
right and sure that sounds interesting
it is i mean
you can read a little book metapolitics
on this but i i think it it cashes out a
lot of what rancher is getting
we got to stick with that versus theme
oh right if we if we do bad u in verses
we got to bring in uh deliz of course
deluse versus bad you and then we can
tag team and zizek versus deliz
because zizek takes bad juice i really
need i need to read the liz just because
why is it that everyone online loves
deliz it's just uh it's it's
it's by far the most popular eric i
thought you had to leave what's going on
feel our street cred fading away
yeah no i must say that's a pretty uh
it's a pretty deep power move
suggesting what our next reading should
be live on the air
kudos
or politics of rupture i think it's best
to always try to find somebody who
espouses the idea in its most
coherent possible term yeah and you keep
saying that matt you haven't
you just because you like someone better
doesn't mean they are better
sure but i mean i thought you would
agree with this right no disagreement
no no but i think that there's no doubt
that you as a systematic philosopher who
talks about these things is
more comprehensive than raw sierra's
right i mean it's not that russia is
better or worse it's just that
he incorporates this into a bigger
project than round sierra does
and trying to figure out how this
event all politics has become popular in
the late 21st century i think that
it's an argument that budget has played
a much bigger role in that than even
someone i actually like rancier quite a
lot to be honest i know it sounds and
maybe it doesn't sound like that but
like of all the edgelord like political
theorists like he's like my favorite one
because uh
because he does all the things that you
have that you normally complain
so to be honest with you the thing the
thing that i really like about ron sear
and like you know i think maybe i know
where
maybe we're getting close to the time to
to end it and the podcast
but you know the thing that i really
like about him is
the claim that like this resistance to
politics has to be momentary
um and that there's always going to be
reconfiguration
of the police order that like you can't
have and and i think the reason i like
it is because i first read him in the
context
of other people who have this i think
really like cringe dream about like this
kind of perpetual political mobilization
where you're always putting pressure
always
and they think that oh maybe we can get
to like a fully unalienated
politics where there's like direct where
we get rid of all the things and what i
like about ron sears
i read him at least as saying well
that's not really possible that's never
going to be possible because
always spontaneously we return to some
sort of a police order
where things get rudenized and common
sense becomes smoothed over
and we and you can only ever achieve
these moments and that seems right to me
so like as a kind of a descriptive
account
i really like him and i think he offers
something interesting yeah i mean
robert dao once said that of all the
emotions that have been most
underestimated by philosophers and in
particular political theorists
boredom is the one that's been paid the
least attention to uh and what i like
around cf4
is his politics is fundamentally one
that's committed to an anti-boredom
right anytime things get stultified
anytime things get calcified
somebody you know as pill said is going
to come along and say this is an
opportunity for me to smash things
up and shake it up to bring something
new into the world right
and i think any caterpillar theorist is
always going to have a little bit of
sympathy for that
what's our ben you mean quote boredom is
the songbird that hatches the egg of
experience and a russell in the bushes
will scare it away
this is a politics of creativity and i'm
happy that the two politics guys
got something out of it because often
your concern is
well what do we what do we do tell me
give me the model give me the structure
give me the thing but if the structure
is always
don't get caught in structure then
that's a
different type of narrativization of the
process of politics
which isn't really political theory
anymore it's kind of a
i don't know what you'd call this yeah
theory well i think
i think i think for me it was useful it
was useful for me to really think about
uh runcier as offering a more of a
descriptive account
like so that's that's the the way in
which i find him to be like useful
um because i just think he's i think his
description of how that process occurs
and
i think there's a way of even reading
history to be uh to be pretty consistent
with what he talks about like the
history of political struggles like i
think there's just a lot to like
in what he's saying about that um but
yeah i mean in terms of who am i going
to go to for like
actually adopting some like political
convictions
i mean ron's here to me it seems very
thin um
other that like but but but but that but
that's not why i like him anyway so
it doesn't matter bills and i started
off by kind of arguing kind of heatedly
about this and this is the thing
i do politics right so i'm always trying
to interpret how interpret how it is
that this can be incorporated into a
kind of more concrete politics you write
about
politics let's be real sorry you write
about politics
yeah sure but i mean that's not to say
that i don't appreciate this the
aesthetic dimension to life a lot right
and quite frankly this really applies to
actually these essays because
i thought that on this essay even though
i tended to agree with it a little bit
more
was really boring right i just kind of
read it and i nearly fell asleep twice
because i'm like oh he's just saying
this whole thing again
ross aaron's essay was lively and vital
and had
interesting examples and was written in
a pretty crisp fashion so
yeah honestly haunted's essay was a bit
of a snooze festival yeah i'd admit yeah
honest was and he was
and i also agree with pills we had a
little exchange
in our pillow pod messenger group and i
absolutely agreed with pills that that
honest seemed
a little bit thick-headed and like
didn't really understand some of the
points that ron sierra was making and i
was like this is just a pretty bad
reading of your interlocutor well he
also admitted that he said i don't i
think there must be an argument here but
it might be one of these three i'm just
not sure which
and it was none of them it's true did
you also do you guys also pick up on the
fact that it always seemed like honest
was trying to find
as i guess a good liberal always tries
to find like points of agreement he was
like i feel like we agree on this i feel
like we agree on this
and then ron sear never did that once he
never was like i think we agree on well
sometimes it's like
always the danger right when i agree
with you but i actually didn't
understand what you said so i'm just
saying i agree with you to shut down the
conversation that always seems to be the
case but then you guys notice there's a
there's a interesting part where ron
sierra was talking about
love and honest picked up on it and
thought it was pretty awesome and he
like
he'd spoke about it i guess this is the
transcript of a dialogue at some points
but
yeah he spoke about it afterwards saying
like that that was a pretty cool thing
but i didn't
totally understand it but it seemed like
a normative thing that ron sear was
doing right he was saying like this is
how
love works not like the winnicott sort
of love between
a child and a mother and the mother is
the transitional object
until the child learns to uh love in a
socially correct manner
but he's talking about love as like
inherently multiple
as a sort of aesthetic experience of
narrowing something down to an
individual
and constructing the object of your
desire
and and what like he he talks about this
idea of seeing like a gaggle of girls
coming along on the beach
and you sort of fall vaguely in love but
like not with any one of them in
particular
just with like the whole sort of vague
scene
and then as you sort of like the artist
who's you construct the world or you
construct the object
the one of them eventually sort of fits
into it
it's like a dialectical process on an
aesthetic level and
and honest actually seemed to really
like that it was kind of an interesting
exchange at one point
i liked it i was just imagining some
just perverted frenchman sitting with
his cigarette
he's like 65. he's 65 on a on a beach in
southern france and there's a bunch of
girls walking forward and he's like
yeah we could have a creative act
together right yeah
lots of body hair going around i like
french theory for that also right
because
victor i'm sure maybe you'll agree with
me on this maybe it won't but one of the
things that you'll very rarely see
political theorists who aren't martha
nosebomb
uh doing is talking about love right at
most you get civic friendship
right that's the kind of idea we're
supposed to aim for it's all there's two
idea
and it's really nice that french
theorists are a lot more less afraid
of tackling those kind of big emotions
and politicizing them
uh in a kind of important way right
because yeah it's true but it's also
worth noting that one of hannah's
uh spheres of recognition is actually
like yeah that's why yeah
and that sort of psychoanalytic
tradition but love then just sort of
boils down to an inter-subjective
relationship
yeah that we have to learn how to do
right otherwise we become
maladapted to uh social norms
you know who else talks about love jesus
badou who matt has committed us to
podcasting about
i just thought roncier's take on love
was much more like rich and
aesthetically yeah exciting and then
from there you want to go yeah politics
of love baby
i love did you guys see ron sierra's
picture on his wikipedia it's just like
him
standing in a meadow with like it's just
it's a strange photo
yeah it looks like he's reaching out to
the stars or something or he's
super hot an old man instagram fail
he's like he's got one strange it's like
he looks a little lost
he looks a little one arm is just right
back to him
he's got a pretty loose sweater it's a
strange it's a strange it's like his
giant eagles about to come land on his
arm again
he's just cast it out i mean let's get
real he's clearly very very high or at
least he's had a couple bottles of wine
his granddaughter was like go out like
the meadow i'm gonna take a picture of
you and then
he kind of drunkenly or highly stumbled
there and then she'd snap the picture
and it's iconic
you know that's a true act of love or he
escapes from his uh
retirement community he's in the field
he's algerian that kind of brings some
of those things
oh yeah yeah everyone from algeria is
daradat
all right guys shall we wrap it up yeah
i think that was
pretty good yeah i'm i made it through
to the end sorry for the exchanges of
of lectures in some cases but uh i think
i think
i don't know who i don't know i i felt
like most of us are i think who who did
that who's responsible for that
i i did one i think
yeah i'd say it's very clearly eric
eric can you just shut the [ __ ] up and
make shorter points please
you love it you all love it all right
are we declaring a winner
uh i mean i think i think i i in my
opinion i felt as though they were um
quality or free match some blows uh but
i think that uh and i also think that
they both kind of talked past each other
but i so i don't know for me it feels a
little bit like a draw
um with good points on both sides
i found it but but honest being more
boring so maybe i give an edge to around
here
bit of a watch centrist i just a bit of
a wash
lost because he's a haber mazian who
showed up to a debate
so that's a big album he's not trying to
win a debate he's trying to reach
consensus on what the right thing to do
is right if he
wins the debate he loses because he
devalues his own political commitment no
the politics of disagreement
i reassert it here and always
yeah all right i didn't actually know
much about either of them when i came in
but i feel like
my sensibilities match up with ron
sierez a little more honest did
have some extremely important points and
valiant criticisms
but ron sierra just had some awesome
points
about recognition and love and all the
rest of it
so i don't know i think i i don't but in
terms of like who wins and
like what's what's a better basis for
addressing injustices
is it is it ron's here's theory of
equality or
or honest theory of uh recognition
i would i would say both leave a lot to
be desired
yeah i'd hesitate to declare a winner
because while my sympathies lie
more with honeth i also thought that
like victor it was an extremely boring
essay
so i'm unwilling to actually say that it
beats up round shares
because even though i found ron sierra's
kind of thin
on the specifics at least i wasn't bored
and i did think the stuff on love was
moving and interesting and important
uh and who doesn't like talking about
you know
allowing more people to narrative art so
i'm actually going to give it to you ron
sierra i like right
here is the winner and next time you
want to pick a political
text uh we could just read the side of a
mayonnaise bottle
just the ingredients list would result
in the same outcome did you really hate
this this much pills do you really hate
it this much
no it's not like you kind of injured i
gotta be uh
this or i gotta extend the politics of
disagreement
to your to your reading choices also
real mayonnaise or uh
salad dressing sauce no just uh miracle
whip
chicken sauce straight up miracle whip
miracle whip i know i don't ever ever
ever talk
to use that oh peace out guys yeah well
god
yeah later
fatality